[Peter] So the simplest way to solve this problem is going to be
by introducing a variable.
Let's call it "first_zip."
To find the first_zip, it's going to be pretty straightforward,
and it's going to give us the location of the first zip.
Now we want to print out the second one,
so let's write "print."
We're going to do text.find again, searching for zip,
but this time we're going to start from the first_zip +1.
If we didn't start from +1,
we would get the result of first_zip again,
and that wouldn't tell us anything about a location of a second zip.
This is one way to solve the problem using a second variable.
Another way to do this without introducing a new variable
is to simply put text.find right where we had first_zip before.